don't hang up what movie is this Chris I
clicked on this video because I was
curious what this movie was well this is
a very limited release horror film that
I went out of my way to see today
because I like the idea of seeing movies
that no one's really talking about it's
opened in like one theater in my entire
area very very small release and I
hadn't heard much about this film this
film is about a group of pranksters who
run a YouTube channel even though it's
not really YouTube it's this movies
version of YouTube and they prank call
people and eventually they get really
good at it and they get a lot of
followers but they go way too far until
one fateful night when they get a call
from somebody saying that they are going
to be pranking them except their idea of
a prank involves a lot of murder and
death and scary things and the tables
are turned now I honestly really liked
the concept of this movie and that's
what got me into the theater today
because I like the idea of a bunch of
people who are doing something that's
very stupid and very dumb and they
eventually have to reap what they've
been sowing which is a lot of pain and
misery for people that concept alone I
think is a really cool idea for a horror
movie and there are a lot of other
horror films where you have a bunch of
asshole young people doing things and
you kind of just want to see them all
brutally murdered by some over-the-top
slasher villain this isn't something we
haven't seen before I just like the idea
of it being kids to our pranking
innocent people having to eventually
deal with the repercussions of doing
that unfortunately I found this movie
pretty bad and a lot of it is due to the
acting this is very very bad acting and
I'm not the kind of person that likes to
zero in on people and trash people in
reviews because I just don't do that I
try to look at a film and I try to
respect the people who make it in this
case I see a very low-budget horror film
that's not opening in too many theaters
and I see a filmmaker who is clearly
really trying to make a good film
because there is actually a substantial
amount of effort given to the direction
in this movie this wasn't like a bye-bye
man where the entire film just feels
like they set up a camera and aimed it
correctly at the people and made sure
everyone was in focus there is actually
an attempt to create some interesting
sequences in this movie and you can tell
the director is trying to boost the
material that the screenplay is because
the screenplay itself how do I put this
it's just one of those movies where the
lights turn off every few minutes and
you never know why somebody somewhere
has a master switch to this house and
it's just playing with every light bulb
in fucking out to constantly every time
characters get scared and walk into a
room the lights just turned off
inexplicably and look oh shit okay oh
I'm gonna look around really really
quietly hey boo that Oh dick who are you
oh oh you're just a member of the crew
Oh how'd you get in the shot
well let's get back to that acting I
admire anybody who tries to make a movie
and I admire anybody who gets behind the
camera and has the balls to act in a
film or direct or write that's hard to
do it's not easy especially when you're
dealing with a big studio system but
this acting is atrocious I can't really
get around it it's some of the worst
I've ever seen in the theater the level
of emotion that's being portrayed
through the actors for these characters
just doesn't correlate with a weight of
films being made the film feels kind of
slow at first like it's building the
suspense of what's happening but
everyone else is always freaking out and
screaming and yelling and crying and
getting all shivery and tense and just
just way over the top to the point where
it's just kind of not working at all for
this film the movie also makes no
logical sense the guy who's on the phone
messing with these kids is able to
control virtually every electronic
device in their house he's like a master
hacker he can send past recorded footage
into their television to play right in
front of them he can access their webcam
on the computer as I already said he can
control every lightbulb in their house
it's absurd and after a while it just
got laughable
I saw a director who was trying to make
a film better than the script he was
handed perhaps this was one of his first
big opportunities and he just wanted to
do his best and I feel like he was
trying really and I do actually feel
like everyone involved with this was
trying their best but it's sad that the
end product will never be good if what's
on the
isn't and the stuff that happens in this
script is so comically absurd to the
point where I was just rolling my eyes
towards the last 30 minutes and I was
hoping it would end soon it also opens
with this big music video style montage
introducing all of the characters who
run this prank website and they
introduced like seven or eight people by
name with these big titles where their
name comes across the screen yet less
than half of these characters play any
significant role in the movie so I'm
wondering why all of them had to have a
big introduction in the beginning
because as soon as that intro was over
they completely forget about all of
those characters and focus on
essentially two of them so we have a
comically absurd villain who can control
all electronic devices in their house we
have some very awful performances a
terrible script that makes absolutely no
sense a couple good ideas the concept
alone I like and an attempt to make a
film better than what was on that page I
can see the director really trying but
in the end the end product of this film
was very bad and that's unfortunate I'm
going to give don't hang up a d-minus
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to this Sunday I'm
going to have my review of x-men 2
posted as always if you like this you
can click right here and get stuff my
nice
[Applause]
[Music]